today but we'll start off with our kitty
he's a four seam slider change up curve
guy he's using his fourth scene majority
time about 55 or seven times so he's
trying to establish that fastball early
in the game and then get guys to chase
after he gets that established i mean
he's in the top five and lowest averages
with that change up so i expect to see
that change up quite a bit today
crawford drives one to right field
there's tucker
floating back he makes the catch mitch
maddie 253 30 home runs and 76 runs
batted in that's pulled
off the third base bag it's a fair ball
and a base hit
for mitch hanigar ty franz hitting 340
since august 10th
he does that a lot of people know but he
hits
opposite field knock he uses the entire
field and now the mariners have loaded
up the bases here in the first with just
one out abraham toro fits the mold as he
digs in with the bases loaded
torah rips one to right field plenty of
open space he's in business and the
mariners crack the scoreboard for first
here's haniger
and seeger will score as well it's a two
rbi two bagger for abriam toro and he
continues to punish his former squad so
the base is still loaded catcher number
eight hitter tom murphy
murphy in the air
who's got it yeah it's gonna be a big
win when it comes down into the glove of
carlos correa
tyler anderson on the mound left-handed
pitcher era at 435 he's been even
stronger since the mariners picked him
up another shrewd move by the front
office brantley is just a guy year in
and year out he gives you consistent
at-bats
and he makes contact on the 1-2 a nice
stop by france at first to the covering
anderson for the out ty france has
played some sneaky good first base d
this year and ty france is a guy that he
had to work on his defense he was
originally in the middle of the infield
he had to work on his defense and he's
arguably the best first facing in the
game in the game right now with
defensive run saves if three now julie
guriel
gets a swing and miss in a strikeout to
end the frame on a 10 pitch first inning
three up three down against a very
potent astros lineup mariners carry
their two-nothing lead into the second
mariners come out of the first with two
runs off jose or kitty and we'll see if
he bounces back here in the second
inning
crawford spins one to left field
brantley chasing it towards the line in
the corner makes the catch for the
second out
[Applause]
one two swing and a miss there you go
after a four two run four hit first from
seattle it's three up three down from
jose or kitty now it's correa mr
walk-off man from yesterday in the 10th
he rips that one right into the glove at
the hot corner of kyle seeger
wow that's rocket retrieval right there
that's when you go into the dugout and
everybody says nice swing and you're
like man i'm not trying to hear that
that should have taken his glove off of
his hand right there
so alvarez at first one out for tucker
tucker in the left center kelnick
chasing it and it's going to hop up
against the wall
alvarez heading for third and he's being
waved home and here he comes throw is
not in time the astros are on the board
it's an rbi double for kyle tucker to
bring home alvarez and make it 2-1 now
marwyn gonzalez some huge hits in his
houston career he played with the astros
from 2012 to 2018. gonzalez takes off to
the crawford boxes
forget about it the astros grab the lead
3-2 off a two-run shot from marwyn
gonzalez
welcome back to houston marvin nice
homecoming right there huh two out
seeger at second base here is terence
mariner's down 3-2 here's the pitch
it's an off-speed pitch pulled to the
left side on a slide as gonzalez gets up
and throws out to wrens beautiful play
to his left for marvin gonzalez doing
what he does and we'll go to the bottom
of the third at minute maid park the
astros lead it three to two here's
christian javier by the way taking over
for jose or kitty two on for seattle
hanager
going after the invisible good little
clinic on the pitch that makes christian
javier so special along with the slider
as he escapes unscathed mid-four astros
up one kyle tucker in the sixth spot
looked like a 2-3 hitter for anyone else
and that one
might hit the top rails
off it goes it's twisting oh
that's in fair ground
oh tucker trucking for third
and he is
oh well you don't see that every day
what a way to start the inning i mean
that was truly a moon shot as you're
running full speed it's very difficult
to gauge when you need to slow down now
two down with tucker at third or that's
a comebacker and a really nice recovery
from tyler anderson after the lead off
wacky triple from kyle tucker abraham
toro is one for two
and hits the first pitch the other way
left center field meyers chasing it and
he's
got the baseball
now heading back to first and in there
safely is kyle seeger jake myers with
the closing speed wow what a catch what
a great play altuve the lead off man
homer yesterday 2-1
is ripped left field does he have it on
back-to-back days
he does
jose all too bad and homer for about a
month goes along yesterday and doubled
up this afternoon it's number 27 on the
season make it 4-2 houston the bases are
loaded for houston key spot in the game
tyler anderson removed for casey sadler
and myers does take off gives that one a
ride to deep center field but kellnick
is there so it all worked out for scott
service top of the order jp crawford two
on one out as jp crawford strikes out
nice pitch from raley
anager bounces out look at bricks brooks
rayleigh come in and pick up two outs
strikeout ground ball and the seattle
mariners strand two here in the sixth
it's kind of like a punt and bare hand
joe smith throw did he stay on the back
yes ty france did for out number two who
said pitchers aren't at least that was a
very athletic play
right there by joe smith bill may time
pra in the four and a half range going
up against jared kelnick the rookie goes
after the first pitch and puts it in the
air myers tracking back similar spot
where he made a catch this time he's
going to have to play it off the wall
and the mariners are going to tie up
this game jared kellnick has himself a
two rbi double one pitch from phil matan
turns into a 4-4 contest ty france
climbs in a single a double and two
strikeouts
and he pulls one third base side
and this will do it wasn't the smoothest
date for kendall craveman but no runs
come across for seattle they strand two
in scoring position and this game
remains tied at four two one two away
and here is jose mar malleos
up the middle he comes through
the mariners grab the lead back with one
and here comes another
dylan moore and jared kellnick score
it's six for seattle huge hit for
marmaleo's right there to come through a
clutch situation well here's your lefty
swinger
j.p crawford
crawford drives one to deep right field
tucker looking back and forget about it
it's gone jp crawford for two to make it
eight for seattle
huge hit hanging slider he hangs it i'll
bang it muscle up mr leadoff man there's
a 93 mile an hour fastball yesterday
from seawall that was put over the wall
in the first home run for bregman since
june 9. bregman's mostly been pulling
the baseball lately and he does just
that to the crawford boxes he's got
another
you have your guys
this is becoming a thing right here
alex bregman go long seawall looking for
that 27th out griel
skies one
and here's raleigh
game
over the seattle mariners top the
houston astros on a wednesday afternoon
by a final score of eight to five and
they salvage a game in this three-game
set